freue mich sehr dass Volker wissigen bei
mir ist Generalsekretär der FDP Herr
Wissing was war das denn gestern für
eine Nacht für Sie
eine schöne wir haben uns riesig gefreut
über dieses Vertrauen der Wählerinnen
und Wähler aber wir sind uns natürlich
auch bewusst dass vor uns eine große
Aufgabe liegt ja wie werden denn jetzt
die nächsten Tage aussehen können Sie
uns das schon mal beschreiben was Sie
erwarten ich habe bis gestern spät und
heute morgen erstmal viele Interviews
gegeben viele Fragen tauchen jetzt
natürlich auf wir werden in unseren
Gremien der Partei heute das
Wahlergebnis analysieren werden
miteinander besprechen was der nächste
Schritt ist aber wir bleiben bei dem was
wir vor der Wahl gesagt haben wir sind
gesprächsbereit mit den Parteien der
demokratischen Mitte es gibt zwei
mögliche Konstellationen die das Land
noch vorne bringen können das ist ja
Meike oder die Ampel und das muss jetzt
ausgelotet werden und hatten sie dann
zwischen den Interviews auch mal Zeit
mit den Mitbewerbern zu sprechen per SMS
oder am Telefon wir sind natürlich im
Gespräch wir als Generalsekretäre und
natürlich auch in anderer Konstellation
wir haben ja auch in den Ländern
gemeinsamen reg etwas Verantwortung und
sprechen miteinander das ist normal man
gratuliert sich auch zu den Ergebnissen
und ich glaube ein gutes menschliches
Miteinander sollte man gerade in so
schwierigen Zeiten auch
parteiübergreifend pflegen Menschen
müssen miteinander reden die
Demokratie ist ein Auftrag die
Gesellschaft zusammen zu halten und dort
wo sie auseinander zu laufen droht sie
wieder zusammen zu führen und das geht
nur wenn man über die eigenen
Parteigrenzen hinweg denken reden und
handeln kann und bei uns Journalisten
stellt sich ja dann auch jetzt schnell
die Frage wer spricht zuerst mit wem was
sagen sie dazu zu den Vorschlägen das
jetzt erstmal sie die FDP mit den Grünen
spricht und man dann schaut wie man
gemeinsam der CDU oder der SPD
entgegentritt wenn man zusammenarbeiten
möchte muss man zunächst einmal
miteinander reden und das kann natürlich
in einer 3er Konstellation nicht so sein
dass man nur immer mit einem Partner
spricht also das FDP und Grüne auch
miteinander reden halte ich für absolut
sinnvoll und richtig das ist ja auch
nicht gegen andere Parteien gerichtet
sondern wir sind ja selbstständige
Parteien mit einem eigenen Programm für
das wir gewählt worden sind und müssen
an die Interessen unserer Wählerinnen
und Wähler denken die ja in ganz
bestimmten Auftrag gegeben haben und das
kann man nur erklären wenn man auch
bilateral miteinander redet
sie haben immer gesagt sie werden nicht
für Koalitionen sondern für Inhalte
damit war die FDP ja auch sehr
erfolgreich konnte ihr Ergebnis von 2017
verbessern und gestern waren dann immer
so Worte wie Aufbruch im Raum der Status
Quo darf nicht so weitergehen
gleichzeitig haben sie aber auch gesagt
wenn sie sich die Inhalte anschauen dann
gibt es da mehr Überschneidungen mit der
Union die allerdings hier in der Wahl
doch als Wahl Verliererin rausgeht wie
wollen Sie diese Aufbruchstimmung mit
einer Wahl Verliererin
verkörpern nun die Union hat ein
Programm vorgelegt dass uns näher ist
als das Programm von SPD und Grünen aber
die Union hatte ein solches Programm in
den letzten 16 Jahren wiederholt
vorgelegt aber immer daran gearbeitet
ist selbst nicht umzusetzen oder nicht
umsetzen zu müssen ich erinnere an die
Weigerung der Union Steuerreform
zwischen 29 und 213 in Angriff zu nehmen
oder auch an das beharrliche weigern der
Union 2017 mit der FDP in einer
Jamaika-Koalition Steuerreform auf dem
Weg zu bringen das ist in der Tat ein
Problem die Union ist eine
reformverhinderungspartei gewesen aber
wir wollen ja nicht zurückblicken
sondern nach vorne und deswegen müssen
wir auch ausloten ob die Union jetzt
denn bereit ist das was in ihren
Parteiprogramm steht auch tatsächlich
umzusetzen oder ob sie sich wieder mit
Händen und Füßen wird insofern das
werden spannende und interessante
Gespräche aber klar ist auch so wie
unser Land da steht kann es nicht
bleiben die Welt hat sich um uns herum
verändert und
Reformen sind ein wichtiger Motor ein
Land international wettbewerbsfähig zu
halten Deutschland ist nicht irgendeine
Volkswirtschaft auf uns schaut die Welt
und auch Europa hängt vom Erfolg
Deutschlands ab und dieses lethargische
wir verändern nichts dann müssen wir es
auch nicht erklären das ist glaube ich
jetzt nicht mehr angebracht und das war
auch der Grund warum die große Koalition
so schlecht da steht ich meine muss wie
ich das vorstellen die regieren seit 16
Jahren ein Land und sprechen dann selbst
davon dass wir ein modernisierungs
Jahrzehnt brauchen also das zeigt ja die
ganze Zerrissenheit auch und die ganze
Misere aber jetzt schauen wir nach vorne
die Wählerinnen und Wähler haben ja
mehrere Optionen uns eröffnet und das
ist ein gutes Signal wir wollen nach
vorne schauen aber auch im Vergleich zur
Vergangenheit ziehen denn sie waren ja
nun schon in Sondierungsgesprächen was
wird denn diesmal anders werden als 2017
wie will sich auch die FDP anders
vielleicht Verhalten in den
Verhandlungen
2017 wurde der Fehler gemacht dass die
CDU sich mit den Grünen darauf
verständigt hat zu regieren und man
davon ausging dass die FDP dafür einfach
die Hand heben werde sowas kann man
nicht ernsthaft in Erwägung ziehen das
wird aber auch keine mehr tun die FDP
ist sehr eigenständig sie hat ein
eigenes Programm die Union hat ja alles
getan um Wählerinnen und Wähler von der
FDP wegzubringen das ist nicht gelungen
die uns gewählt haben wollten unsere
Inhalte haben und das zeigt auch dass es
ein großes Erwartungshaltung für die
Inhalte der FDP gibt und jetzt wollen
wir Gespräche führen in aller
Sachlichkeit aber auch mit den
notwendigen Ernst am Ende muss eine
Dreierkonstellation sich die Frage
stellen ist sie ein Mehrwert genau in
dieser Konstellation für das Land soll
sich solche Regierungen die zustande
kommen weil man keine anderen Mehrheiten
hat davon halte ich nicht viel ich
glaube man muss wirklich ausloten bringt
diese Konstellation in Mehrwert und
jetzt geht es für mich um die Frage oder
für die FDP Umfrage was bringt
Deutschland besser voran Jamaika oder
die Ampel und Sie haben ja nun auch
wirklich Erfahrung in einer 3er
Koalition als ehemaliger
stellvertretender Ministerpräsident
Rheinland-Pfalz und zwar mit einer Ampel
was können sie aus ihrer Zeit in
rheinland-pfalzen und für die
Verhandlungen mitnehmen wichtig ist dass
man sich auf Ziele vollständig hinter
denen sich alle versammeln können eine
Regierung in der jeder ein Teil seines
Programms auf den Tisch legt und man das
dann zu irgendeiner Patchwork Kunst
zusammenfliegt davon halte ich nicht
viel jeder muss hinter allem stehen in
der großen Koalition haben wir erlebt
dass die einen gesagt haben wir müssen
Dinge umsetzen die wir nicht wollen weil
der andere das will das überzeugt ja
keinen Bürger man hat dann den Eindruck
es wird der Macht willen Politik gegen
die eigene Überzeugung gemacht das trägt
nicht wir müssen ein gemeinsames
Regierungsprogramm entwickeln hinter dem
alle stehen und sagen das ist richtig
weil und das ist
das was eine schwierige Aufgabe ist weil
natürlich die Parteien vor den Wahlen
und das ist ja Auftrag mit sehr
unterschiedlichen Profilen in die Wahl
gehen sonst hätten die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger ja keine Auswahlmöglichkeit
gleichzeitig müssen wir aber am Ende
immer die Demokratie auch als
inklusionsauftrag begreifen unsere
Aufgabe besteht jetzt darin nicht mehr
die Unterschiede zwischen den Parteien
als Trennendes vor uns her zu tragen
sondern unsere Aufgabe besteht jetzt
darin einen Regierungsprogramm aus den
unterschiedlichen Politik Ansätzen zu
erarbeiten dass jede und jeden mitnimmt
am Ende darf die Gesellschaft nicht zu
verlieren werden es gibt bei Wahlen
immer Parteien die Gewinner und
Verlierer sind wichtig ist dass nach
einer Regierungsbildung die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger alle zu gewinnen werden
Stichwort mitnehmen es gibt ja einige
Mitglieder von denen man erwarten kann
dass ich nun nicht unbedingt eine Ampel
Koalition möchten wie schaffen Sie es in
den Verhandlungen die Basis mitzunehmen
also zunächst einmal wir sind noch nicht
in ampelverhandlungen aber wir sind dann
nach wie vor offen und haben eine andere
Präferenz ja auch geäußert aber
gleichwohl ist es wichtig dass man die
Mitglieder mit Inhalten überzeugt jetzt
zu sagen wir finden eine bestimmte
Regierungskonstellation nicht so gut
weil wir ein anderes Parteiprogramm
haben das ist ja nicht wirklich tragend
am Ende kommt es darauf an dass man mit
möglichen Koalitionspartnern einen
Vertrag verhandelt von dem die
Mitglieder auch unserer Partei sagen das
ist ein Mehrwert für unsere Gesellschaft
so stellen wir uns den Beitrag der
Freien Demokraten in einer Regierung vor
wir haben vor der Wahl gesagt das ist
eine Richtungswahl und die Messlatte für
uns wird am Ende sein ob es in die
richtige Richtung geht natürlich aus
unserer Überzeugung deswegen sind wir ja
auch in bei den Freien demokra